has an NDA we are kickin back and I saw
this story that those kinda interest and
you know that Google
wants to put and literally everywhere
every part of your life if Google has
their way is going to have an air
involved in it in a a a letter that they
sent to the SEC
at this is just incredible they are
saying that they hope will
and on who refrigerators car dashboard
thermostat classes and watches to name
just a few possibilities
this has something to do with them by
Amnesty nest make these like fancy
home thermostat and literally all these
products that we have in our homes
thermostats your car all this stuff
is gonna and even though you the for you
like it so I i find it that way because
you know whether on BCS the yeah I see a
few
you know your surgeon on Wed forget it
happened co-ed
but now near by are still going to be
connected somehow
so they'll every made the purchase yeah
there's to those
put a ring on it and then it brings a
whole set about watching you all the
time
and they know how I their houses and the
jump in your car the No will review and
over that you are the energy located
and all that stuff they this year future
at
no I mean if you like this is a good
thing that consumers can fight back
against
had all my thermostat were at 11 and
refrigerator and yeah that sounds
ridiculous and
you know how only the product can be
here 3l and get
who lost appetite as much as possible
that's how we are able to use their
service their search engine for free
at home it makes also squirrel but
there's 1000 reason right as James A
you don't have to ask my refrigerator or
your car
any we wat our products the asset Lee
sleazy and if they're not we're not
gonna buy so I think they have to tread
carefully with this I don't know exactly
how do you plan on doing
but you got me the product nice to look
at norms in one adult every single
object their home don't you think it's
gonna be one of those things where it
happened so slowly
that we're just miss will he accept it
like everything else you need like with
all the technology
just more intrusive stuff keeps coming
and I think how do you find it you know
you for like your friends are gonna have
you know
smart cards or whatever it is and
they're gonna be doing it and then
you're gonna be alright
how was your car because they're you
know I or whatever whatever the
yeah concerned about the privacy issue
right so
you know work without all these new
appliances and
late Ke$ha Souls Day all all the things
that were buying
%uh Xboxes watching you yeah
I worried about the camera on my laptop
all the time were
cameramen I had a long time and so
I remember there was this one me three
journalists who thought I was crazy that
Michael Hastings want to cover his
%uh his webcam and by the way my
you know let your reporter Diana really
tragic car accident
you're a girl in June arm so I
how knowledge I it might use it paranoia
but I think those
is legitimate considering the fact that
so many companies one knows so much
about my personal life
Lee in solid third parties so they can
you know get advertisers to target ads
the NSA spying on us like the privacy
issues or concerns
yeah for me it's like half privacy just
what you're entitled to your own home
that we should be subjected to
advertising everywhere that
and then of course you said deal with
all that stuff who's watching as and
when can
and all that happened I hope not
swatches right now ok
don't